foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
general Douglas MacArthur
arrived at atsugi Naval Aerodrome near
Yokohama
on August 30 1945
as he emerged from his aircraft
he paused at the top of the steps
stuck one hand in his hip pockets
tightened his Jaws around his corn cob
pipe
and surveyed the conquered lands
[Music]
this pose was repeated several times
from different angles
so that all the Press photographers
could get a decent shot
democracy was to be instilled in the
Japanese people
as though they had never heard of it
[Music]
our problems in the brain inside of the
Japanese head
these brains like our brains can do good
things
or bad things
all depending on the kind of ideas that
are put inside
[Music]
foreign
plays featuring loyal Samurai were
banned or heavily censored
as were books and films about the
bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
satirical cartoons of MacArthur and
mention of occupation censorship was
strictly forbidden
[Music]
the commission finds you guilty is
charged and sentences you to death by
hanging
umashita himself thanked the commission
for the fairness of his trial
[Music]
prime minister at the time of the war in
the Pacific General Tojo remarked during
his trial
none of those Japanese would dare act
against the emperor's will
the cross-examination was immediately
cut short
and a week later Tojo dutifully stated
that the emperor had always loved and
wanted peace
General had Nike Tojo who assumed
official responsibility for the conduct
of the war and did everything possible
to exonerate his emperor
MacArthur would later remark to the U.S
Senate that in terms of modern
civilization
the Japanese were like a 12 year old boy
[Music]
[Music]
you are interested in the unknown the
mysterious the unexplainable that is why
you are here
when the war was over bank loan books
had deteriorated
the assets the banks held were mainly
war bonds and Loans to destroyed
Industries
as such the whole banking sector was
virtually bankrupt
this problem was easily solved by the
bank of Japan
all it had to do was buy the banking
sector's bad papers with newly created
Reserves
giving them good money for assets which
were often worthless
the first two post-war Central Bank
Governors were nominated by the U.S
occupation
ikichi Iraqi was appointed the first
post-war Governor as the bank of Japan
but soon after taking up this post he
was indicted by war crimes prosecutors
and had to resign
then in 1951 after a general Amnesty on
suspected war criminals filling public
officers
he was made ambassador to the United
States
on returning from his post as Ambassador
in 1954
Iraqi was again made governor of the
Central Bank
after the 1951 amnesty for war criminals
much of the Japanese wartime bureaucracy
was returned to their wartime positions
this included wartime politicians
and most home Ministry bureaucrats who
had been in charge of the thought police
a number of which moved to the education
Ministry
Japan is the key to the fate of the Far
East
once again for the second time in the
march of modern history
those words have urgent reality
in order to avert the kind of rural
unrest that was helping the Communists
in China
the Americans initiated the
redistribution of land from Big
landowners to their tenants
foreign
known as the zaibatsu were purged as
supporters of a criminal War
and prohibited from further business
activity
basically the fascist policies of the
30s that the the reform fascist
bureaucrats could not Implement during
the war even yes the U.S occupation
managed to complete like the Land Reform
and right these policy yeah it's a very
funny uh Encounter of Japanese wartime
fascists and American new dealers
[Music]
the diet home of Japan Senate and House
of Representatives
in Japan fnatic students and left his
speech rioted for days on end
see with America
the Socialist deputies staged
to die in itself
the police in restoring order also
evicted the Socialists
foreign
[Music]
to the platform and called order the
session that approved the treaty
in 1957
the former Class A war crime suspect
Kishi nobosuke became prime minister of
Japan
he had been General toja's minister of
Commerce and Industry during the war
where his responsibilities that range
from Munitions to slave labor
while Hitler's
wartime war minister War economy
Minister was in Berlin Spandau prison
yes
his Japanese wartime colleague was prime
minister right of the country although
Kishi became a defender of democracy
after the war
before and during the war he had
described himself as a national
socialist
with money from crime syndicates
industrial corporations and CIA funds
Kishi built the liberal Democratic party
into a powerful political machine
in Japan
many of the most important post-war
economic and political leaders came from
an elite group of wartime bureaucrats
the very same people who had pushed
Japan into the war
a liberal Democratic party stayed in
power for almost 40 years
foreign welcome home in Japanese to
these American soldiers after a tour of
Duty in Korea they are returning to
their base in Japan where once a short
time before they were stationed as
occupation troops and how do they return
how are they received by the people
whose land they occupy not as overlords
not as antagonists not as men who are
distrusted and feared and presented but
as friends
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
board the Ministry of Finance had its
headquarters
from here the ministry controlled most
aspects of economic life in Japan
the Ministry of Finance was
the most powerful Ministry and the bank
of Japan had to report to the Ministry
of Finance
Ministry of Finance officials elicited a
deep and hushed exclamations of awe and
respect
and former Ministry bureaucrats obtained
influential posts as heads of private
and public institutions
[Music]
but in one area the ministry did not
have actual control
and that was the quantity of credit
creation and its allocation
which was decided by the Japanese
Central Bank the bank of Japan
they told the Ministry of Finance and
the public and the journalists
we run monetary policy through interest
rates
and they let the Ministry of Finance
reign in their interest rate policies
but the rule was done through not
interest rates which is the price of
money it was done through the quantity
of money
[Music]
it worked this way it's called window
Guidance the bank of Japan just told the
banks how much they were going to lend
they will have to lend in the coming
quarter and who which sector of the
economy to lend to it's credit
allocation Credit Control the bank of
Japan gave quarterly instructions to
individual banks on the value of loans
and which industrial sectors they should
be allocating to
all loans were broken down in sectors
and sub-sectors
and large-scale borrowers had to be
listed by name
[Music]
the bank of Japan could decide which
project should be encouraged and which
should be discouraged
by dictating to whom and for what banks
could issue loans
[Music]
this was the war economy system adapted
to the production of consumer goods
[Music]
the 95 million people of Japan now enjoy
a national income second only to the
United States and the more prosperous
nations of Western Europe
it's not a good system for capitalists
you know shareholders
but for the population it created a lot
of wealth very even income and wealth
distribution very high growth and very
rapidly raised quality of lipo stands a
bit
in 1959 alone the economy expanded by 17
percent
but a result of the war economy system
was that entire industrial sectors would
compete not for profit but for market
share
companies would fight until bankruptcy
to gain market share
this phenomenon was soon recognized and
called excess competition
the solution was the creation of
explicit or implicit cartels
in the banking sector window guidance
acted as the cartel control mechanism
because the bank of Japan could dictate
the number and value of loans that Banks
issued
as a result Bank rankings never changed
during the post-war era except after
mergers
according to one Banker if it were not
for window guidance we would compete
until Haruki
the U.S current account deficit surges
to its highest level in nine years the
size of the increase took many economies
by surprise
while cartels controlled competition
within Japan
there were no such limits when it came
to International markets
Japanese corporations soon became
dominant in many markets in the world
[Music]
in America
formal Congressional hearings were held
under the title Japanese productivity
lessons for America
[Music]
leading economic theories indicate that
only free markets can lead to success
but Japan Rose within decades to become
the second largest economy in the world
without relying only on the Invisible
Hand of free markets
Japan's post-war economy was a fully
mobilized War economy
with production shifted from weapons to
consumer goods
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
since the bank of Japan presented itself
as a champion of free markets
window guidance was an embarrassment
official Publications either failed to
mention it
or downplayed its role by calling the
credit controls voluntary
whenever the Ministry of Finance would
inquire about the bank of Japan's credit
creation and allocation policy
Bank of Japan's staff would engage in
complex discussions full of technical
jargon
to make the process appear impenetrable
to non-experts
in November 1965
the first batch of Japanese government
bonds came onto the market
from now on when politicians wanted to
spend more they would no longer put
pressure on the bank of Japan
but instead exerted on the Ministry of
Finance
so the ministry would ultimately preside
over an ever increasing national debt
Mountain
foreign
[Music]
the 1980s was an era of financial
deregulation in industrialized world
most industrialized countries lifted
their restrictions on the movement of
capital
foreign
[Music]
a former governor of the bank of Japan
called for a five-year plan for the
transformation and liberalization of the
Japanese economy
[Music]
then in 1986
The Advisory Group on economic
restructuring headed by the former bank
of Japan governor
iroa mykawa
proposed a 10-year economic reform plan
designed to make the living standards of
Japanese more comparable to those
enjoyed in the West
The Proposal stated that
time has now come for Japan to make a
historical transformation
in its traditional policies on economic
management and the nation's lifestyle
there can be no further development for
Japan
without this transformation
[Music]
the report read like a wish list by U.S
trade negotiators
it started with calls for administrative
reform and the abolition of bureaucratic
powers
the goal was the transformation of the
entire body politic
the abolition of the war economy system
and the introduction of a us-style free
market economy
those members of The Advisory Group who
uttered descent
were relieved of their duties
[Music]
reports in the Press were highly
critical
observers recognize the radical nature
of the plan
it seemed far too ambitious
it was calling for a wholesale
revolution of all parts of the Japanese
economic political and social system
[Music]
foreign
although the report was clear about what
was wanted
it was embarrassingly silent about how
these goals would be achieved
the only clue hidden in the report was
in the implementation of these
recommendations
fiscal and monetary policy have a
significant part to play
[Music]
the bank of Japan has always been on the
record arguing that this typical
Japanese system that we're so familiar
with should be scrapped it just should
be entirely scrapped and U.S star
capitalism should be introduced now
whether you agree with that or not is an
entirely separate question but the bank
of Japan certainly thinks it should be
scrapped and now the next question is
how do you do that well the Ministry of
Finance has been legally in control for
most of the post-war era we've got
entrenched bureaucratic structures
politicians and all these cartels and so
on that was the old system well history
teaches the system changes only
fundamentally if there's a crisis
[Music]
the commission proposed that monetary
policy should be used to promote a
historic crisis
sufficiently large to overcome the
vested interests of the Ministry of
Finance
politicians
and corporate Japan
[Music]
every system has groups that benefit
from it and hence have no desire to
change it
there is probably no country in the
world that has changed its economic
social and political system in a
significant way without a crisis
[Music]
it is the crisis that convinces citizens
and interest groups of the Need For
Change well and how can you achieve this
um well you need a crisis the best way
to create it is to have a bubble because
that's how nobody stops you
[Music]
the bank of Japan began to significantly
increase window guidance loan quotas
average yearly loan growth quotas were
close to 15 percent in the late 1980s
[Music]
one city Banker would later remark
during the bubble we wanted a certain
amount of loan increases
but the bank of Japan wanted us to use
more
[Music]
ideas
foreign
[Music]
caused not only a boom in real estate
but also in the stock market
between 1985 and 1989
stocks Rose
240 percent
and land prices
245 percent
[Music]
by the end of the 80s the value of the
garden surrounding the Imperial Palace
in central Tokyo was worth as much as
the entire State of California
[Music]
although Japan is only 1 26th the size
of the United States
its land was valued at four times that
of the United States
[Music]
the market value of a single one of
Tokyo's 23 districts the central chiod
award
exceeded the value of the whole of
Canada
economists who are trained to believe in
Market outcomes
tried to justify the high land prices
some thought land scarcity was the
reason
shiny new corporate headquarters Rose in
Tokyo's Posh business districts
[Music]
the labor market boomed so much
that there was a genuine fear of a
serious labor shortage
companies started to invite final year
University students on expensive trips
to Holiday resorts
to entice them to sign up
[Music]
the politicians loved it the Minister of
Finance loved it we had a boom tax
revenues going up the companies loved it
everything was wonderful in the bubble
era
Joshua
nominated
with asset and stock prices rising
inexorably
even traditional manufacturers could not
resist the temptation to try their hand
at playing the markets
soon they expanded their finance and
treasury divisions to handle the
speculation themselves
these company hedge funds known as zytec
use borrowed money to engage in property
and share speculation
the frenzy reach such proportions
that many leading manufacturers
such as the carmaker Nissan made more
money through speculative Investments
than through manufacturing cars
literally thousands of Articles were
written on the new Japanese Miracle
economy
a common explanation by economists was
that high and Rising productivity
explained the impressive performance of
Japan's economy
books on Japanese management techniques
became International bestsellers
Western businessmen read 17th century
tracts on Samurai strategies
in reality
Japan's Stellar performance in the 1980s
had little to do with management
techniques
instead of being used to limit and
direct credit
window guidance was used to create a
giant bubble
I conducted research actually
interviewing Bank of Japan officers and
bankers on both sides on you know on
tape the result was the bank of Japan
did continue its informal guidance in
fact it was the bank of Japan that
forced the banks to increase their
lending so much
the bank of Japan knew that the only way
for banks to fulfill their loan quotas
was for them to expand non-productive
Lending
in the words of one Banker
if there is no demand for credit from
low risk borrowers and we want to use up
the quota the risk gets worse
another Banker is quoted as saying that
a side effect of the window guidance
rule of loan increases was that the
bank's increased lending even when there
was no loan demand
foreign
like all bubbles the Japanese bubble was
simply fueled by the rapid creation of
new money by the banking system
between 1986 and 1989 toshihiko fukui
was the head of the banking department
but the bank of Japan
this was the department that was
responsible for the window guidance
quotas
when fukui was asked by a journalist
borrowing is expanding fast don't you
have any intention of closing the tap on
bank loans
he replied because the consistent policy
of monetary easing continues
quantity control of bank loans would
imply a self-contradiction
therefore we do not intend to implement
quantitative tightening
with structural adjustment of the
economy going on for quite a long period
the international imbalances are being
addressed
the monetary policy supports this
we have the responsibility to continue
the monetary easing policy as long as
possible
therefore it is natural for bank loans
to expand
why were the banks lending so much well
they were lending so much because they
were forced to do so by the orders of
the bank of Japan
normally Banks choose clients from among
a large number of loan applicants
turning down a significant percentage
but from 1987 onwards the tables had
turned
it was the bankers who were aggressively
pursuing potential customers
anecdotes abound about how the banks
were soliciting loans at bargain
interest rates
pursuing clients like Street Peddlers
Bankers made increasingly exaggerated
assessments of land value
so that the actual ratio of land value
to loan often jumped to 300 percent or
more
to the public this was a strange
phenomenon
people soon dubbed it excess money
only economists analysts and those
working in the financial markets or for
Real Estate firms knew better
they dismissed such simplistic analysis
land prices were going up due to far
more complicated reasons than just
excess money they claimed
Ordinary People simply did not
understand the intricacies of Advanced
Financial technology
when a country creates too much money
some of that money spills out abroad in
the form of Investments
in the 1980s
Japanese Capital flows multiplied from a
net inflow of more than 2 billion
dollars in 1980.
to an outflow of 132 billion dollars in
1986
assets including art objects and other
valuables all over the world
became targets for Japanese buyers
there were high-profile purchases such
as the Rockefeller Center Columbia
Pictures
and Pebble Beach Golf Course
Japanese money bought a staggering 75 of
all United States Treasury bonds
auctioned off in 1986.
[Music]
but it is not easy for a country to just
print money and then go on a shopping
spree around the world
Japan was able to do this
because the markets did not devalue its
currency
the value of individual currencies is
set by currency dealers
if the traditional indicators that the
currency dealers watch do not pick up
the excess money Creation in the country
concerned
then creating large amounts of money and
trying to exchange it for foreign
currency
can work
had pulled off the same trick that the
United States had used in the 1950s and
1960s
when U.S banks excessively created
dollars
Corporate America used this hot money to
buy up European corporations
while the United States had the cover of
the dollar gold standard
Japan's cover
was a significant Trade Surplus
[Music]
[Music]
an early warning indicator of the
build-up of systemic risk in the banking
system
is a ratio of loans for non-gdp based
transactions
to Total loans
this ratio increases significantly in
most countries that are subsequently
struck by a banking crisis
it was this same process that fueled the
mortgage lending and house price Boons
in the United States and the United
Kingdom in the 1980s and the 2000s
the same process also created the golden
20s
in the 1920s United States Banks lent
with stocks as collateral
the principle Remains the Same
as each bank took the stock price as a
given
it created new money
with more money in the stock market
stock prices had to rise
each Bank thought it was safe accepting
a certain percentage of the value of the
stock as collateral
but the actions of all banks together
drove up the overall Market
in Japan
total private sector land wealth Rose
from 14.2 trillion yen in 1969.
to 2000 trillion yen in 1989.
at his first press conference as the
26th governor of the bank of Japan in
1989
yasushi Miano said that since the
previous policy of monetary easing had
caused the land price rise problems
real estate related lending would now be
restricted
he looked around looked at the bubble as
the prices rising you know the the gap
between rich and poor is getting bigger
let's stop it
his name was Mr Nino
and he was a hero in the Press because
he fought against this silly monetary
policy well the fact was he was Deputy
Governor during the bubble era and he
was in charge of creating the bubble
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
land and asset prices stopped Rising
in 1990 alone the stock market dropped
by 32 percent
[Music]
then in July 1991 window guidance was
abolished
this took the window guidance officers
at the bank of Japan themselves by
surprise
Bankers were left almost helpless
they complained that they did not know
how to make their lending plans anymore
in the past when a certain Branch had
said they would like to lend more
they would respond that the window
guidance quota had been used up
now they couldn't do that anymore
as Banks began to realize that the
majority of the 99 trillion yen in
bubble loans were likely to turn sour
they became so fearful that they not
only stopped lending to speculators
but also restricted loans to everyone
else
well it's a bleak Christmas ahead for
Japan the stock market on Monday sinking
to its lowest close in over two years
last week's collapse of one of Japan's
biggest food Traders was the ninth time
this year that a listed company went
under
more than 5 million Japanese lost their
jobs
and did not find employment elsewhere
suicide became the leading cause of
death for men between the ages of 20 and
44.
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
between 1990 and 2003
212 000 companies went bankrupt
in the same period the stock market
dropped by 80 percent
land prices in the major cities fell by
up to 84 percent
some economists seemed relieved
the downturn was evidence that Japan's
economic system was not so successful
after all
meanwhile the governor of the bank of
Japan yasushi Miano
said that
thanks to this recession everyone is
becoming conscious of the need to
implement economic transformation
the Ministry of Finance believing that
interest rates were the main policy tool
put pressure on the back of Japan to
lower interest rates
until the official rate reached 0.1
percent
most economists predicted an economic
recovery
but despite frequent assertions in the
financial press and by central banks
that lower interest rates will stimulate
growth and higher interest rates will
slow growth
there is no empirical evidence for this
relationship
[Music]
Japanese and American businessmen are
meeting here with a plea from Japan
companies for a lower yen
only six percent of Japanese exporters
can make profits with the dollar at less
than 100 yen on average they need the
American currency to rise above 117 yen
to break even
[Music]
the Ministry of Finance asked the bank
of Japan to sell large amounts of Yen
and buy US dollars
so that the exchange rate of the Yen
would fall and exports would pick up
we all know that two of them the
Ministry of Finance moth in Japan and
the bank of Japan they just don't get
along well and what has been happening
also again this month is that the bank
of Japan has been sterilizing its own
intervention well to be precisely
intervention ordered by the Ministry of
Finance the Ministry of Finance tells
the bank of Japan to go out and buy well
we had a figure roughly 20 billion worth
of U.S treasuries but the bank of Japan
is sterilizing this which means it is
basically taking the money from the
economy to fund this purchase most
researchers agree sterilized Forex
intervention doesn't work the boj is
again sterilizing that's why it doesn't
work that's why the Yen has remained
strong
foreign
[Music]
Bank can withdraw money from the economy
by selling its assets
just as it can inject money into the
economy by buying assets
[Music]
when central banks buy and sell assets
they increase or decrease the amount of
money circulating in the economy
[Music]
officials at the bank of Japan ignored
this
and instead claimed that this structural
transformation or reform May produce
deflationary forces in the short run but
will generate a much more efficient
economy after a while
independent observers suggested that
domestic demand had to be boosted by
government spending
and then loan demand would also rise
for a decade the government followed
their advice boosting government debt to
Historic levels
between 1992 and 2002 10 stimulation
packages worth 146 trillion yen were
issued
Verna is
at Jordan Fleming purities in Tokyo he
joins us now to share his views on where
the Japanese economy is heading Mr
Verona good evening to you thank you for
joining us the government was spending
with the right hand putting money into
the economy but the fundraising was done
through the bond market and therefore it
took the same money out of the economy
with a left hand there was no increase
in total purchasing power that's why the
government spending couldn't have an
impact
by 2011
Japan's government debt would reach 230
percent of GDP
the highest in the world
the Ministry of Finance was running out
of options
observers began to blame the ministry
for the recession
and started to listen to the voices that
argued that the recession was due to
Japan's economic system
but how difficult would it have been to
solve the problems of bad debt in the
banking sector and deflation
it turns out that this would not have
been so difficult after all
Financial system always looks like
Catch-22 there's no long growth so
there's no economic growth so there's no
longer also there's no economic growth
well
there is one thing that can break
through that this circular argument
that's the Central Bank the job of the
Central Bank in this situation is to
print money
foreign
what we need now is more radical
measures and there are some painful ones
but they're also painless ones the
Central Bank could for example just buy
all bad debts at face value Japan would
have the strongest banks in the world
to bail out the banking sector a central
bank can buy up the bank's bad financial
assets with newly created money
giving them face value for assets which
are often worth significantly less
[Music]
this is what the bank of Japan did after
the war
alternatively money could be transferred
to the banks by helping them make
sizable profits
one way this can be achieved is for the
central bank to corner a market
in effect creating a mini bubble in a
certain Market in which banks invest
heavily
providing large profits for them
this turned out to be a relatively
common technique by central banks to
help their banking systems
[Music]
other proposals include measures to
introduce zero risk borrowers to Banks
or introducing accounting changes that
help their balance sheets
in Japan
the authorities and the bank of Japan
argued as did the Western Powers almost
two decades later
that the taxpayer should foot the bill
in March last year as you may remember
the government injected a large amount
of money
into some 15 major Japanese national
institutions and we were one of them
yeah
that helped us
right of bad debts and also to beef up a
capital base so that we would be
prepared to lend
tax money has been used to recapitalize
Banks
however there is no evidence that
taxpayers have been responsible for the
bank's problems
therefore such policies have likely
created a moral hazard
[Music]
the money supply is determined by the
net increase in money creation by Banks
and the central bank
if moral hazard dictates that the
banking sector should not be bailed out
deflation and recession can still be
avoided by the central bank
to do this the central bank can increase
the money supply
a central bank can increase the amount
of money in an economy at any time
without limit
by simply buying assets from the private
sector and paying with newly created
credit
[Music]
the bank of Japan could for instance
have bought real estate and converted it
into public parks
and there is an opportunity here to
solve three problems in one stroke the
economy needs money creation the banks
need to get rid of their bad debt and
the real estate sector needs some
transactions well
what you can do is just have the Central
Bank print money
um buy the land from the banks turn it
into parks and actually you solve
another problem quality of life in Japan
even if the bank of Japan had later sold
these parks at a fraction of the cost
it would still have made money
because it costs a central bank nothing
to create the money in the first place
another option for injecting money into
the economy is quantitative easing
despite having all these options
available the bank of Japan at every
stage refused to implement policies that
would resolve the crises
when I was at the bank of Japan 9293 as
a visiting researcher
I was convinced that this recession was
going to get really bad so any Bank of
Japan guy who I could get to talk to me
I would ask well
why aren't you printing more money I
noticed they were not printing enough
money and and I met one guy who was
quite open about that he said Richard
yeah sure we could have printed more
money we could have created a recovery
but then nothing would have changed
Japan's economic structure would not
have changed
now that time I still wasn't ready to
believe that the bank of Japan was
seriously prolonging the recession on
purpose in order to get structural
changes that just seemed a bit too wild
Finance Minister masojiro shiokawa has
turned to the bank of Japan asking it to
help stop deflation or fight deflation
at least the bank of Japan consistently
defied calls by the government Finance
Minister and prime minister to create
more money to stimulate the economy and
end the long recession
at times the bank of Japan even actively
reduced the amount of money circulating
in the economy
which worsened the recession
[Music]
the bank of Japan's arguments always
came to the same conclusion
namely that the blame lay with Japan's
economic structure
Central Bank staff even argued that
significant monetary easing could cause
harm
by inducing a further delay in the
progress of structural adjustment
[Music]
the early post-war Japanese leaders knew
that they were running a war economy
but they chose not to talk for political
reasons
the Cold War propaganda message was that
post-war Japan had adopted a U.S style
political and economic system
unwilling to tell the truth the early
post-war leaders took their intimate
knowledge about the origins of Japan's
Miracle economy with them to their grave
a generation of bureaucrats and
politicians reigned in the 1980s and
1990s who did not understand the true
character and purpose of their own
country's economy
a whole generation of Japan's economists
had been sent to the United States
to receive phds and mbas in U.S style
economics
since neoclassical economics assumes
that there is only one type of economic
system
namely unmitigated free markets where
shareholders and Central Bankers ruled
Supreme
many Japanese economists quickly came to
regurgitate the arguments of U.S
economists
[Music]
the U.S and Japan closed two days of
insurance talks on Tuesday primary
sector deregulation
is needed to overcome the entrenched
interests
of large insurance companies life and
non-life
and the Ministry of Finance
bureaucracy they need to reach an
agreement before December the 15th after
that date the U.S has threatened to
impose trade sanctions will key move
analysts are expecting the
securitization of real estate or will
the package be enough for more we are
talking to Richard Werner to have
meaningful securitization we need
deregulation and that's already the
answer to your question to get
deregulation you have to reduce the
power of the Ministry of Finance and
obviously the ministry was resisting
that
in the 1980s
persons who could introduce themselves
with a business card from the renowned
finance ministry
illicited deep and hushed exclamations
of awe and respect
but by the mid-1990s attitudes had
changed
there now seemed little doubt to most
observers that the Ministry of Finance
had caused the recession
the frequent demonstrations were held
outside the ministry's doors
by citizens disgusted by the bureaucrats
actions
in early 1998 Public prosecutors for the
first time raided the most powerful of
Japan's Ministries
both Banks and their Regulators were
heavily criticized for their actions
scandals highlighted some of the
informal links that existed between
Ministry of Finance officials and
bankers
many Bank staff and even some Ministry
officials were arrested and imprisoned
and several committed suicide
as Central Banker masaki shirakawa had
explained
it is not easy to change the
institutional framework and promote
structural reform
since it necessarily involves the vested
interests of all the related individual
economic agents
while Yutaka Yamaguchi a Deputy Governor
of the bank of Japan
had said that the bank of Japan had
faced the big dilemma that monetary
easing would produce the mitigation of
immediate risks
which in turn would result in a delaying
of adopting ultimate Solutions
from the mid-1990s onwards
the government began to dismantle much
of the power structure of the Ministry
of Finance
the bank of Japan on the other hand saw
its influence grow significantly
you have written just recently there's
no doubt in your mind a central bank the
bank of Japan will be cut loose from the
Ministry of Finance and become pretty
much independent putting it on a footing
with other central banks briefly why are
you so sure basically the Ministry of
Finance which had been controlling
legally at least the bank of Japan I
mean that's what the law says has lost
all credibility the Minister of Finance
is being blamed for the creation of the
bubble for the long recession and for
many other problems which had which had
we had recently in Japan whereas the
bank of Japan has been out of the
spotlight of public criticism and it's
using that now to say well the mob has
been bad we need Independence now
Richard thanks very much I have been
speaking to Richard Werner Chief
Economist at Jardine Fleming Securities
in Tokyo
[Music]
soon after his retirement from the
position of governor of the bank of
Japan in 1994.
mienno embarked on a campaign
giving speeches to various associations
and interest groups
he lobbied for a change in the Bank of
Japan law
his line of argument was to subtly
suggest that the Ministry of Finance had
pushed the bank of Japan into the wrong
policies
to avoid such problems in the future the
bank of Japan needed to be given full
legal Independence
according to Miano
making central banks independent
reflected the human wisdom that had been
nurtured by history
in 1998
monetary policy was put into the hands
of the newly Independent Bank of Japan
so you're saying that politicians as
well as economists should be putting
more pressure towards the bank of Japan
in order to create more money but a lot
of critics are going to say that that is
intervening into the central bank's
Independence what do you make of that
um I think I think that's exactly right
that is intervening in the central banks
Independence and that's exactly what we
need
foreign
[Music]
scandals that followed the bursting of
the bubble also brought down the 1955
system of one-party rule by the liberal
Democratic Party
in the old system politicians did not
compete by proposing different policies
policy was made by the bureaucrats
and politicians merely focused on
appeasing local constituencies with
Public Works projects
in October 1997 for the first time in
post-war history
all policy initiatives to stimulate the
economy originated from politicians not
bureaucrats
then in early 2001 a new type of
politician was swept to power
Japanese government bonds staged their
biggest rally this month as junichiro
koizumi emerged as the hot favorite to
become the country's next prime minister
junichiro koizumi became prime minister
in terms of his popularity and his
policies he is often compared to
Margaret Thatcher and Ronald Reagan
his message was simple
no recovery without structural reform
[Music]
at the Geneva Summit in July 2001 he
said
some say recovery comes first without
reforms
but if the economy recovers the will to
reform will disappear
therefore after the elections I will
continue with the plan of no growth
without structural reform
during 2001 the message of no economic
growth without structural reform had
been broadcast on an almost daily basis
on the nation's TV screens
foreign
[Music]
believes we need structural changes we
need to scrap Japanese style capitalism
to get a recovery why it seems we tried
all the policies it seems we've tried
everything nothing works so the system
itself the Japanese style economic
system must be to claim so we better get
rid of it
[Music]
Japan was shifting its economic system
to a U.S style market economy
and that also meant that the center of
the economy was being moved from Banks
to stock markets
to entice depositors to pull their money
out of Banks and into the risky stock
market
reformers withdrew the guarantee on all
Bank deposits while creating tax
incentives for stock Investments
as U.S style shareholder capitalism
spread unemployment Rose significantly
income and wealth disparities Rose as
did suicides and incidents of violent
crime
then in 2002 the bank of Japan
strengthened its efforts to worsen bank
balance sheets and force Banks to
foreclose on their Borrowers
until then hakua yanagasawa Minister for
financial services had resisted the bank
of Japan inspired proposal to inject tax
money into Banks
effectively nationalizing them taking
over their management and using this
power to call in loans from companies
thus triggering many bankruptcies of
large firms
[Music]
Mr yanagasawa was duly sacked by the
Prime Minister and replaced with hazo
takanaka
takinaka was a supporter of the bank of
Japan's plan to increase foreclosures of
Borrowers
Minister takinaka was trying to
implement a policy to actually
dramatically weaken the balance sheets
of the banks in order to give him a free
hand and allow him to nationalize them
takanaka appointed a task force to
oversee the banking policies
which included two former bank of Japan
staff
one of them Takeshi Kimura immediately
demanded that accounting changes be
implemented which would worsen bank
balance sheets and render
nationalization unavoidable
takuru morinaga a well-known Economist
in Tokyo argued forcefully that the bank
of Japan inspired proposal by takanaka
would not have many indigenous
beneficiaries
but instead would mainly benefit U.S
vulture funds specializing in the
purchase of distressed assets
these vulture funds had faced the
difficulty that despite over 200 000
bankruptcies
few firms sufficiently large for the
vulture funds to be interested were
bankrupted
when kimuras and fukui's support for the
bankruptcy plan was voiced
the former operated a private company
that advised on the securitization of
distressed assets
and the latter was an advisor of the
Wall Street investment firm Goldman
Sachs
one of the largest operators of vulture
funds in the world
Mr fukui also his mentor Mr meeno and
and his mentor Mr Mai Kawa and you
you've guessed it these are some of the
princes of the Yen that the book is all
about they have said on the record in
the 80s and also throughout the 90s what
is the goal of monetary policy it is to
change the economic structure now how do
you do that well you need a crisis and
that's really what they've done they've
written a crisis
thank you so much and we apologize
she don't understand
the department responsible for the
window guidance quotas at the bank of
Japan was called the banking department
and who was in charge of this the man
the head of this banking Department
inside the bank of Japan during the
bubble from 86 to 89 was toshihiko fukui
Mr fukui the current governor of the
bank of Japan he's the man who created
the bubble
when fukui had become governor of the
bank of Japan
he would say while destroying the
high-growth model
I am building a model that suits the new
era
they have succeeded on all counts if you
look at the list of their of their goals
and you know it was more than a wish
list it's more or less a plan that they
mapped out they wanted to achieve
they've reached all those goals destroy
the Ministry of Finance break it up get
an independent Financial supervisory
agency reach Independence for the bank
of Japan Itself by changing the bank of
Japan law
um and engineer deep structural changes
in the economy
um by shifting from manufacturing to
Services opening up deregulating
liberating liberalizing privatizing the
whole lot
in the 1920s Japan's economy in many
ways resembled today's U.S economy
with Fierce competition aggressive
hiring and firing takeover battles
between large corporations few
bureaucratic controls strong
shareholders that demanded High
dividends and corporate funding from the
markets not Banks
yet throughout the post-war era Japan's
economy had been the opposite
highly regulated with cartels limiting
competition
Bank financing and cross shareholdings
reducing shareholder power
no takeovers and a frozen labor market
with lifetime employment and seniority
pay
it was claimed that to end the recession
and improve performance
Japan must shift from welfare capitalism
back to shareholder capitalism
yet it remains unclear why a country
that had run a consistent and
significant balance of trade surplus
would need to change its economic system
to become more competitive
[Music]
Japan was not the only high performance
economy in Asia that in the 1990s found
itself in the deepest recession since
the Great Depression
[Music]
in 1997 the currencies of the Southeast
Asian tiger economies could not maintain
a fixed exchange rate with the U.S
dollar
they collapsed by between 60 and 80
percent within a year
[Music]
the causes for this crash went as far
back as 1993.
in that year the Asian tiger economies
South Korea Thailand and Indonesia
implemented a policy of aggressive
deregulation of the capital account
and the establishment of international
banking facilities
which enabled the corporate and banking
sectors to borrow liberally from abroad
the first time the post-war era that
borrowers could do so
[Music]
in reality there was no need for the
Asian tiger economies to borrow money
from abroad
all the money necessary for domestic
investment could be created at home
indeed the pressure to liberalize
Capital flows came from outside
since the early 1990s the IMF the World
Trade Organization and the U.S treasury
had been lobbying these countries to
allow domestic firms to borrow from
abroad
they argued that neoclassical economics
had proven that free markets and free
Capital movement increased economic
growth
once the capital accounts had been
deregulated the central banks set about
creating irresistible incentives for
domestic firms to borrow from abroad
by making it more expensive to borrow in
their own domestic currencies than it
was to borrow in U.S dollars
domestic local interest rates were high
or higher than the US dollar interest
rate
okay and the exchange rate
was virtually fixed it was the
government and the central bank that
said we will maintain the exchange rate
that's right that's right central banks
of uh of Thailand and other East Asian
countries resisted exchange rate
adjustment uh and they they tried to
send the signal that they would protect
the exchange rate
the central banks emphasized in their
public statements that they would
maintain fixed exchange rates with the
US dollar
so that borrowers did not have to worry
about paying back more in their domestic
currencies than they had originally
borrowed
when I went to Thailand I was actually
on an ADB Mission as an outside
consultant
I went straight to the bank of Thailand
and asked them were there any informal
credit guidance schemes and they were
surprised that I asked this question
because of my study of Japan I thought
perhaps there's something similar and
they told me it was a young staff who
perhaps wasn't aware of the politics
involved he said yeah yeah we have this
credit planning scheme
Banks were ordered to increase Lending
but they were faced with less loan
demand from the productive sectors of
the economy
because these firms had been given
incentives to borrow from abroad instead
they therefore had to resort to
increasing their lending to higher risk
Borrowers
[Music]
Imports began to shrink
because the central banks had agreed to
Peg their currencies to the U.S dollar
the economies became less competitive
but their current account balance was
maintained due to the foreign issued
loans
which counters exports in the balance of
payment statistics
when speculators began to sell the Thai
baht the Korean Won
and the Indonesian rupee the respective
central banks responded with futile
attempts to maintain the peg
until they had squandered virtually all
of their foreign exchange Reserves
this gave foreign lenders ample
opportunity to withdraw their money at
the overvalued exchange rates
the central banks knew that if the
countries ran out of Foreign Exchange
Reserves
they would have to call in the IMF to
avoid default
and once the IMF came in the central
banks knew what this washington-based
institution would demand
for its demands in such cases had been
the same for the previous three decades
the central banks would be made
independent
on the 16th of July the Thai Finance
Minister took a plane to Tokyo
to ask Japan for a bailout
at the time Japan had 213 billion US
dollars in foreign exchange Reserves
more than the total resources of the IMF
they were willing to help
but Washington stopped Japan's
initiative
any solution to the emerging Asian
crisis had to come from Washington via
the IMF
after two months of speculative attacks
the Thai government floated the bot
the international monetary fund to date
has promised almost 120 billion dollars
to the embattled economies of Thailand
Indonesia and South Korea
immediately after arrival in the
crisis-stricken countries
the IMF teams set up offices inside the
central banks
from where they dictated what amounted
to terms of surrender
the IMF demanded a string of policies
including curbs on Central Bank and bank
credit creation
major legal changes and sharp rises in
interest rates
as interest rates Rose
high-risk borrowers began to default on
their loans
burdened with large amounts of bad debts
the banking systems of Thailand Korea
and Indonesia were virtually bankrupt
even otherwise healthy firms started to
suffer from the widening credit crunch
corporate bankruptcies soared
unemployment Rose to the highest level
since the 1930s
the role of the fund in coming to the
rescue of ailing Nations has been
fiercely debated some have even accused
the IMF of actually making Asia's
economic crisis worse even if they have
to subvert our economy they will do so
just to prove that they are right the
IMF has not been very helpful
the IMF knew well but the consequences
of its policies would be
in the Korean case
they even had detailed but undisclosed
studies prepared that had calculated
just how many Korean companies would go
bankrupt
if interest rates were to rise by five
percentage points
the imf's first agreement with Korea
demanded a rise of exactly five
percentage points in interest rates
the IMF policies are clearly not aimed
at creating economic recoveries in the
Asian countries they pursue quite a
different agenda and that is to change
the economic social and political
systems in those countries in fact the
IMF deals prevent the country's
concerned like Korea Thailand
to reflate interesting you're saying
it's making the crisis worse and you're
suggesting that the INF has a hidden
agenda well I mean it's not very hidden
this agenda because the IMF quite
clearly demands that the Asian countries
concern have to change the laws so that
foreign interests can buy anything from
Banks to land and in fact the banking
systems can only be recapitalized
according to the IMF deals by using
foreign money which is not necessary at
all because as long as these countries
have central banks
they could just print money and
recapitalize the banking systems you
don't need foreign money for that so the
agenda is fairly to crack open Asia for
foreign interests
the IMF demanded that troubled Banks
would not be bailed out
but instead closed down and sold off
cheaply as distressed assets
often to large U.S investment Banks
one positive coming out of Thailand is
that there'll be auctioning off some
major assets from 56 finance companies
in your view should
um
some of the owners from the 56 finance
companies be allowed to buy back their
assets
in most cases the IMF dictated letters
of intent explicitly stated that the
banks had to be sold to foreign
investors
and let me emphasize in that respect
that these reform programs are the key
the absolute key
to restoring Financial stability for the
first time ever South Korea closed five
banks in a major step toward meeting its
IMF mandate
the number of commercial Banks has
declined has been reduced as a result of
closure margins and Acquisitions and
they foreign strategic investors are now
in which which is a remarkable change
in Asia government organized bailouts to
keep ailing financial institutions alive
were not allowed
but when a similar crisis struck back
home in America a year later
the very same institutions reacted
differently
the connecticut-based hedge fund
long-term Capital Management
which accepted as clients only High net
worth individual investors and
institutions
had leveraged its 5 billion dollars in
client Capital by more than 25 times
borrowing more than 100 billion US
dollars from the world's Banks
when its losses threatened to undermine
the banks that had lent to it
with the possibility of a systemic
banking crisis that would endanger the
U.S financial system and economy
the Federal Reserve organized a
cartel-like bailout
by leaning on Wall Street and
International Banks to contribute funds
so that it could avoid default
yeah I mean you're right the the views
from Washington and New York seemed
certainly quite flexible because soon
after they told all the Asian countries
no bailouts for financial institutions
when then long-term Capital Management a
hedge fund in New York almost went past
suddenly a bailout was organized just
contradicting what they'd said to the
Asian countries but they say that there
are no public money used for ltcm but
the meeting was held famously inside the
federalism right
why would the United States make demands
on foreign nations in the name of the
free market
when it has no intention of enforcing
the same rules within its own borders
[Music]
the examples of the Japanese and Asian
crises illustrate how crises can be
engineered to facilitate the
redistribution of economic ownership
and to implement legal structural and
political change
today similar events are at work in the
Eurozone area
countries within the euro currency block
have forfeited their right to a national
currency
handed this power to the European
Central Bank
with me here in the studio is Richard
Werner he's the professor at Southampton
university Richard was an advised to the
bank of Japan and the Ministry of
Finance at the end of the the bubble
area in the 1990s watch your advice to
ECB they meet tomorrow what would you be
what would you be telling them
um well again they have to focus on the
quantity of credit creation more than
interest rates the ECB has a lot to and
to learn from its past mistakes because
basically I think it didn't really watch
carefully enough credit creation where
in Spain
Ireland we had a massive credit
expansion under the watch of the ECB
they didn't look at that interest rates
of course are the same in the Euro Zone
but the quantity of credit Cycles very
different there's one interest rate for
the whole Euro area but in 2002 the ECB
told the bundespunk to reduce its credit
creation but the biggest amount in its
history and told the Irish Central Bank
to print as much money as if there's no
tomorrow what do you expect is going to
happen same interest rate with the same
growth no recession in Germany boom in
Ireland which one tells you that which
variable credit creation
from 2004 under the ecb's watch Bank
credit growth in Ireland Greece Portugal
and Spain increased by over 20 percent
per annum and property prices
skyrocketed
when Bank credit fell property prices
collapsed developers went bankrupt
and the banking systems of Ireland
Portugal Spain and Greece became
insolvent
the ECB could have prevented these
bubbles just as it could have ended the
ensuing Banking and economic crises
but it refused to do so
until major political concessions had
been made
such as the transfer of fiscal and
budgeting powers from each sovereign
state to the European Union
in both Spain and Greece youth
unemployment has been pushed up to 50
percent
forcing many youths to seek employment
abroad
Greek doctors for whose education Greek
taxpayers have paid
now work in Germany
the deliberations of the ecb's
decision-making bodies are secret
the mere attempt at influencing the ECB
for instance through democratic debate
and discussion is forbidden according to
the Maastricht treaty
the ECB is an international organization
that is above and outside the laws and
jurisdictions of any individual Nation
its senior staff carried diplomatic
passports
and the files and documents inside the
European Central Bank
cannot be searched or impounded by any
police force or public prosecutor
the ECB is well known among economists
as one of the world's most powerful and
least transparent central banks
yet its former president Jean-Claude
triche
dealt with this problem by merely
asserting that there was no problem
the ECB is one of the most transparent
central banks in the world
and has helped Define the
state-of-the-art of Central Banking in
this domain he claimed
the gentleman over there yes please my
name is Richard van I'm an economist my
question is who's also been for years
member of the governing Council of the
ECB the question is where the Mastery
treat to your ECB statutes does it say
that is the job of the ECB to back
structural reform or any other political
agenda I said very very clearly and we
have all said very very clearly that we
had no responsibility in this domain we
have a voice and we say in this domain
and in some others what we think and
perhaps if we can help in explaining
from our side to the general people that
they would be better off perhaps it
would help Europe embarking in this
implementation of structural reforms
which is so important and there is a
consensus on that the diagnosis again is
a very very very large consensus on this
on this point
foreign
commission an unelected group whose aim
is to build the United States of Europe
with all the trappings of a unified
state
has an interest in weakening individual
governments and the influence of the
democratic parliaments of Europe
[Music]
it turns out that the evidence for
Central Bank Independence that was
relied upon in the Maastricht treaty
derived from a single study that was
commissioned by none other than the
European commission itself
published in 1992 under the name one
market one money
the study purported to demonstrate that
Central Bank Independence led to low
inflation
James Ford an Oxford academic
has since demonstrated that this study
was manipulated to obtain the desired
result
the story we're being told by the
central banks just does not add up and
there is evidence that central banks
work
differently from what they would like us
believe as to how they work
the world over
central banks hold significant yet
little understood powers
often independent unaccountable and
obscure
central banks operate in the shadows yet
their actions affect us all
central banks in almost all countries
worldwide and the IMF has helped a lot
in achieving this they've become totally
independent and in practice not
accountable to any Democratic
institution and accountability to
parliaments is usually minor and in
practice meaningless
whether it is the Bank of Japan the
Federal Reserve the bank of England or
the European Central Bank
examples of Central Bank deception
abound
in the United States in the 1920s Banks
were encouraged to create money and give
it to speculators
[Music]
the resulting depression persuaded the
freedom-loving Americans that a
decentralized federal system without
strong National controls could not work
[Music]
in the 1990s the Japanese were persuaded
that their economic system
which had brought considerable
prosperity and equality
needed to be changed into a so-called
free market system
and while Japan's transformation was not
yet complete
the central Bankers struck again
with an imf-led raid on the Asian tiger
economies
[Music]
the present European debt crisis
is yet another example of Central Bank
deception
to create a public consensus for the
need for structural reform
by purposefully creating a recession and
then needlessly prolonging it
must constitute an abuse of power
do citizens really want to be
manipulated in such a costly and
dishonest manner
talking about body party
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]